By comparing multiple sequence alignments, we can arrive at
a consensus sequence for a transcription factor binding site
that's optimal. Now when scientists normally carry experiments like
this out, they may compare tens, hundreds, and even thousands
of sequences. And what this means is, that we
will end up with a consensus sequence that no
individual sequence in our analysis actually had, and that's
okay. We still reason that the consensus sequence itself is
the optimal binding site. And that any deviation, any
variation from this sequence would result in reduced binding
or activity. Of course in the end, any claim
like that must be tested empirically in the lab.